russian forces are continuing their
attacks on ukraine's main cities russia
claims it has taken control of the city
of kherson in ukraine's south the
governor there says the city is
completely surrounded elsewhere a
government building was a blaze in the
city second city of harkif which has
come under days of airstrikes
authorities say russian paratroopers
have also landed there they say more
than 20 people have been killed and 100
injured in khaki in recent days and the
mayor of the port city mario poll says
it is under constant bombardment
let's bring in inna sofsan she is a
member of the ukrainian parliament and
joins us from kiev welcome uh you know
originally from kharkiv ukraine's second
largest city that has suffered heavily
from russian bombardment over the past
days so what are you hearing from there
what's happening there
uh i am indeed from harukeva uh i'm
seeing bombs blowing up in the city they
have bombarded the area where i grew up
uh the bomb the one that he reported
about in the city center it's it's blown
up i just
well 10 minutes walk from my school
which i graduated from 20 years ago so i
am getting many messages from people
even if those people i haven't been in
touch with for years but they're all
texting me and saying this we want those
fascists out of our city we want uh
hurricane to stay ukrainian
and that is a largely russian-speaking
city that is important to to explain to
the international audience because putin
has been
claiming that he is coming here to
give freedom to the russian speakers
well now russian speakers in hakeem are
asking for him to leave their city so
that they can live in independence over
in ukrainian state
the the situation in hercules and it's
terrible they are
bombing it from sky
but uh what gives me hope is that after
three days of heaviest bombardments of
the city which have destroyed i don't
know how much of the infrastructure
it destroyed hospitals and and
authority buildings but uh they didn't
manage to get into the city on tanks so
the city is very well protected by the
ukrainian army on the ground the only
thing that we we have difficulty
covering is the sky that is why they're
using this advantage in order to uh
bombshell uh my native city
so you are a member of parliament uh for
a party that is normally an opposition
to president zelinski uh are you
supporting him in this situation is
ukraine really pulling together
i am a representative of the opposition
party we do have many disagreements with
the lansky political party but as of now
we all stay united we all just want
russians out of our country and then we
can continue our
democratic criticism of the of the
government but as of now uh there is
nothing we can argue about because the
only thing we all want as of this time
is for russians just to get out of our
territory to get out of our land
now a few days ago sitting in a bomb
shelter you wrote an article about how
the russian president has quote fatally
underestimated ukrainians what do you
mean by that
well putin uh when uh when starting his
uh troops invasion into ukraine he was
thinking that he will be fighting
ukrainian army uh which is uh of course
smaller than the russian army but as a
matter of fact he is fighting the whole
of the ukrainian people right now
because everyone is getting involved
everyone is volunteering everyone is
ready to take the guns
i'm seeing more than 100 000 people who
signed up voluntarily for territorial
defense units including my dad i'm
seeing women of middle age who don't
know how they can be of help they're
making food for the soldiers
i'm seeing people on the streets in
eastern
towns where the russians come and they
claim that they take over control of the
city what those people are doing and
that is just amazing i'm still i'm
almost crying when watching those videos
they are doing the most ukrainian thing
you can imagine they go to the main
street to the main square and protest
against the russians in their city and
they actually managed to kick out
several in several cases russians on
tanks from their cities with their bare
hands just by by yelling at them by by
setting molotov cocktails
which do set their tanks on fire and and
i think that is something that putin did
not take into account is that he is
actually fighting not 215 000 ukrainian
soldiers he's fighting 40 million
ukrainians
now the united nations says it expects
four million ukrainians to flee the
country and that's ten percent of the
entire population as a member of
parliament do you encourage people to
leave as long as it's possible or to
stay
uh well i as a member of parliament but
also as a mother i do understand the
desire to make sure that your child is
safe
and from what i am seeing uh from the
the reports we're getting uh those who
did leave uh mainly women with their
children and again as a mother i would
say that after i heard the first bombs
after first explosions in kiev the first
thing i did
i called my uh my son's father and we
had an arrangement that in case some
things start happening he will be taken
our son to the west of ukraine and that
is what he did and then i could proceed
with him with my job here as a member of
parliament so i believe that the
majority of those who left are
well women with children and i do
understand this i very much hope that
they will be able to return safely to
their home cities and towns
i cannot
encourage or discourage this i do
understand the situation they're in and
i really really want
all people to be safe but particularly
because we are seeing that putin is
targeting civilian targets as of
yesterday we had
17
confirmed death of children
after the shellings and the shootings on
the street here in kiev so putting his
skill in our children so making sure our
children are safe is is a huge priority
again i understand that not just just as
a member of parliament but as a mother
myself but i do hope that they were able
to return back to ukraine after the
victory
i'm afraid we have to leave it here in
assassin there a member of the ukrainian
parliament talking to us from keith
thank you very much for joining us here
thank you news
let's have a quick recap of the
situation on the ground in ukraine
russian forces are intensifying their
attacks on ukraine's main cities russia
claims it has taken control of her son a
city in the south close to crimea their
governor there says it's completely
surrounded russian paratroopers have
reportedly landed in ukraine's second
biggest city harkief
russia has warned residents there to
flee as it plans further airstrikes like
those seen in recent days
a russian missile strikes a tv tower in
kiev in kharkiv a government building
goes up in flames
both attacks killed people
[Music]
russia is ramping up its assault on
ukraine
as a 60 kilometer long russian convoy of
armored vehicles closes in on the
capital
thousands of ukrainians are still
desperately trying to flee
those staying behind are facing the
horrors of war
had a fight at 5 00 a.m
we were retreating and near us
a meter away from me
and mine blew off my friend's arms and
legs
i tried to save him i pulled him away
but he didn't make it
mean
ukraine's president vladimir zelensky
has asked nato to set up a no-fly zone
and has also applied to join the
european union
we are fighting
we
are showing everybody that's exactly
what we are
so do prove that you are with us
do prove
that
you will not let us go
it was an impassioned plea for help
as the political discussions continue
the ukrainian fighting spirit remains
strong
auntie w correspondent matthias
birlinger now joins us from levithan
western ukraine for the latest from the
ground there matthias reports are coming
in that the russian military has taken
control over the city of kerason what
more can you tell us
well it's a bit unclear at the moment
what we've seen is pictures of tanks
inside the city center of garcon near
the railway station and also some
administrative buildings it seems that
they have entered the city whether they
have full control or not is unclear
where fighting seems to be going on uh
the ukrainian side denies that the
russians have taken full control and are
saying that they still control parts of
the city i think we'll get a clearer
picture in a few hours or maybe days
so ukraine's president vladimir zelinski
uh gave a a an address today and he
sounded very defiant let's listen to
what he said
you do make this
just think about this figure
almost 6 000 russians died
russian servicemen within six days of
war a figure without the enemy's losses
from the past night
six thousand to get what ukraine
it is impossible
it will not happen with rockets it will
not happen with bombs tanks any strikes
we are on our land and there will be an
international tribunal to prosecute them
for the war against us
president vladimir zelinsky there's uh
he mentioned the ukrainian estimate of
russia's death toll so far what do we
know about uh
morale among russia's military and
indeed on the ukrainian side
yeah this is the ukrainian estimate of
course you need to treat this with
caution there are no numbers by the
russian side published by the russian
side also there are no numbers published
by the ukrainian side on ukrainian
losses or at least no no full figures um
but what we see from uh
lots of reports that we're getting from
the from society not only from the
military is that russia seems to have uh
miscalculated this this uh
incursion and they were not well
prepared we are hearing stories about
tanks running out of fuel on their on
their way to to attack
ukrainian cities we are hearing about
russian soldiers begging for food in
some places um this seems to have been
extremely badly planned we're also
hearing from as well from russia less so
but also from ukraine that many soldiers
don't seem to know that they were
invading ukraine this is hard to believe
but there are uh stories uh where
soldiers were told they were sent on an
exercise and then they found themselves
facing a civilian population for example
that
was hostile to them um and
it's it's it's very hard to assess right
now what the situation is whether these
are single cases or whether this is
systemic it it is something that the
soviet union and russia have done before
that they bring in young recruits
without giving them the full picture we
are also hearing that communication
is often lost for these
these groups their cell phones have been
have been confiscated so they cannot
report back from the front but they were
not given proper maps that's something
the ukrainian military says that they
have not found a single map inside uh
these vehicles that they have captured
so
it's the picture that we're getting now
now we need to really be careful with
this because this is a war and every
site gives only the information uh that
they want to give but the picture that
we're getting now is that this has been
a terrible misplantification
misconception of this in incursion badly
equipped badly prepared russian military
but a russian military that has a lot of
arms a lot of tanks and a lot of
manpower so
we shouldn't draw the conclusion from
this that this is over in any way uh i
think this is this might be lasting for
some time even despite these reports
parts of uh those uh that that manpower
and that weaponry uh seems to be forming
a massive column of uh uh on the
outskirts of o'keeffe is the capital
capable of repelling an attack attack by
a force like that
well you could expect that the capital
is one of the most uh fortified places
one of the places that ukraine has
prepared to defend it's a question of
course on how long this will last and
also how well russia organizes their
support from the other side
we see all these vehicles on satellite
imagery but we don't really know how
well they are for example uh equipped
with with fuel with food how long they
can stand there they don't seem to be
moving at the moment we also don't know
what they're meant to do are they meant
to invade into into the city and engage
in fights in the streets of kiev or are
they meant to encircle the city to lay
siege on the city this these two things
are completely different and they would
need a completely different response
from those who defend the city so that's
very hard to say at the moment um we see
it's an impressive number and we've seen
impressive numbers all over now of
course on the ground we are also seeing
that ukraine has been prepared much
better than many have thought
dws matthias billinger there joining us
from la vie thank you very much mathias